overall you know knowing that some of
you had experiences where you got
married and some of you didn't
um how would we rate this experience do
we feel like having gone through this
love is blind or do you feel like no no
it's not blind like there's maybe blind
physically but like there's a lot more
that you need to know emotionally to
really connect with somebody I think
Love is Blind yes
will you marry me will you marry me will
you marry me
oh
our side but also just like maybe you're
blind to some things within yourself and
you can that's how you learn about
things is going going through something
like this you learn so much so yeah you
have like an Awakening within yourself
on certain things that you've gone
through and they may not have noticed
about yourself and maybe faults that you
have and something to learn from so but
love is also blindsided so you know
there's that too there's that too I just
say love it love is blind
um physically I didn't have any problem
um but I think love love is not numb
like love still feels so that's my
takeaway like physically yes 100 I can
see past someone what they physically
look like but I still very much feel
Raven when did you feel like SK was
somebody that you could see yourself
having a real relationship with yeah I
think when we came back to real life we
started living together in Dallas I got
to see uh really like the progress of
our relationship ship every single day
every day we were able to communicate
more to combine Our lives our schedules
we went back to work immediately and I
fell in love with him more every day
just feeling like okay I could really
live this life forever with this man so
after doing that for however long we did
up into the wedding you know I was ready
to go it re it really reassured me that
you know we could start from really
really low and build our relationship to
something
that I thought was really beautiful
I mean I give you I gave you a lot of
credit for you know willing to
um you're to sort of like acclimate
yourself to sk's culture uh you know and
the same thing with with Brennan
um when did you have a feeling did you
have a feeling that he was gonna say no
it seemed like that was the one of the
bigger Shockers of of this you know of
this group
I do not
I knew that it could be 50 50. like you
guys saw our wedding was first so we
kind of stopped filming and went
straight into it we didn't have a lot of
time to like talk and really get into it
but like I said like I was in a great
place I knew that he was in a great
place and we both really had the
commonality that like regardless of what
happens like we know what it is and we
can make it through anything so it was
kind of timing right and it was really
timing with our entire relationship with
the move you know it we had things
playing against us but I knew that it
would be okay but I didn't know exactly
what he was gonna say and I clearly like
did not prepare myself for that very
well you guys spoken since then oh yeah
yeah we're super good yeah not together
though still together
I can't answer that
okay fair enough you guys obviously hit
it off right from the very beginning
um congratulations on on getting married
you take him to be your husband how is
wedded life is it great it's it really
is um I've said this a few times but a
lot of people say it's the hardest thing
that they've ever done I think it's the
easiest thing I've ever done like it was
there was never really a question if we
were gonna get married it was
he re-proposed every single day he
proposed to me leading up and it was
always a yes there was never a question
in my mind he really is just the
greatest team of being on Earth and he
he has a lot of he's funny as [ __ ] he is
there's a lot more too and we make
perfect sense like I think there's like
such it's there's painted like such a
stark contrast between us but he is he's
the Cutie like he's he's me you know and
so
um there was never a question if it was
going to be yes or no in past in past
series of all this blind we've seen a
difference in religion become a really
big factor in the relationship but it
wasn't for you guys at all when did you
guys have that was that conversation had
in the pods was it had out of the pods
where he said that I mean I was
surprised like you know I mean it makes
sense but he was like yeah I'll convert
not a big deal I'm happy to do it I
think it was day two and um you can see
that conversation like my like
fundamental part of me is being Jewish
um I'm not religiously Jewish but I am
very proud to be a Jew
um and that he's not religious and he's
like I love that and I was like you know
our kids are going to be Jewish
and he was like yeah absolutely I've
seen nothing wrong with that
um and he was just really excited he's
like I Love Culture I love learning new
things and like let me know what I need
to do to make you comfortable with this
if that's converting like 100
um and we've Revisited a few times like
with you know talking about having kids
now we're just you know
um do we want to
do that and I'm like it's I don't want
to ever Force anyone to do anything so
if that's like completely up to you
how's his shikshuka it is better than
mine and it is [ __ ] come on we have
had a shishuka off and his was way
better
um which was annoying I mean I'm saying
they're eating it and I'm like God this
is so good like what the [ __ ] but knows
we have done it and he's he's really
good dad seems to like him has does he
like him more now my dad
the day that they met we did like a
whole like toast like doing shots and my
dad's like Mazel Tov welcome to the
family and I'm literally sitting there
like what the [ __ ] is happening right
now like I was confused because I
thought that was gonna be a bigger
hurdle than it was my dad's a very tough
individual
um
I didn't see it being that easy I knew
that my dad would really like him and
respect him Brennan is a very
respectable man yeah I'm such a
gentleman and he's very like very funny
very sarcastic very similar to my family
and so I knew that they would get along
it was just getting them to accept like
you know hey we're gonna get married and
like you know tomorrow so yeah yeah so
it was it was weird and everyone just
really embraced us and we were
questioning them like are y'all okay
like y'all are seriously okay with this
and they were so yeah it's really
incredible well congratulations uh as
any of you and and Cole you know I see
when you guys are are working when
you're clicking you guys are really
really clicky and obviously when you're
not it it doesn't really work out so
great but from
from early on did you guys feel like you
were clicking even prior to his
conversation and this moment in the pool
and you guys have hashed and rehashed on
the show
um was that as as big a blow as it as it
seems like it was on the show the reason
that we kind of kept revisiting is just
the the acknowledgment that that was
wrong and inappropriate on Cole's end
didn't happen really for weeks so that's
kind of why we kept revisiting it and I
just couldn't put it to bed because it
was like hey man you still haven't said
like hey this was wrong or like he while
he had apologized to other people
apologized to Colleen and Matt I still
hadn't gotten an apology so we did
revisit it
um and it it was something that of
course seemed like I
a couple of times yeah I mean and then
when we get to the wedding there's
a Haymaker
it's not a gamble It's a Fight For Love
your side gets up and clears the room
were there things that we had not seen
on camera I think they're specifically
you have this you say something up to
Alonso like he made advances at women
was that prior to your relationship do
you feel like he was making advances
during your relationship I do believe it
was during
um I from as early on as as soon as we
got engaged to write up until bachelor
party really um so there where there was
a lot that you know the world didn't get
to see I didn't just say no to the cool
that everyone got I said no to the cold
that I got yeah
um and there was a lot and I I stand by
everything I said everything I said had
a meaning and a reason why I said it
didn't do it to humiliate him it was
more so just to be factual and hope that
he would be a changed man for his next
healthy relationship that I hope we have
yeah
um I hope you're single and loving it
and having a good time I am good good
DMS are open yeah
for you guys you know you guys not
knowing until the very last minute that
was probably one of the biggest
surprises of the finale episode to me I
have no clue what's gonna happen we've
gone through a lot of conflict we're
hours away and I still don't have a
decision I don't want to be heard by
someone that I love a game you know are
there things that you guys fell in love
with each other in the pods over that
have bloomed and taken themselves
further you know since you guys have
gotten married yeah we we started off
our relationship
always laughing but making each other
comfortable to open up more and I
expressed it a few times throughout the
process that it's not that I don't want
to be vulnerable I just don't know what
that means for me personally yeah yeah
and that's one of the main reasons why I
fell in love with Matt because I felt so
comfortable and I never felt that before
with another person yeah yeah so just
building on that relationship or
building on that communication and keep
building on that that's what's really
blossomed into our marriage now and any
time now that we run into conflict the
first thing that comes out of Matt's
mouth is how do we compromise on this
let's talk it out and I you know I
applaud and I thank the Love is Blind
process for helping us we would have
never met on the outside world and we
would have never built this strong
communication that we have now Nancy you
wrestled with a lot while the show was
happening bartis the you know saying
that he was attracted to Raven
um the abortion conversation do you look
back at this experience and say you know
you have regrets or do you look at it
and say like you you made the right
decision all the way through
in the moment it was the right decision
looking back at bartisa's perspective
and the things that he was interviewing
and saying about and talking to the boys
about
um I wish he was having those
conversations with me and so I think had
he opened up and told me his doubts
throughout the last two weeks then my
answer would have been different because
it was two weeks before the wedding I
told him I was going to say no and he
wanted a second chance which is what he
did
[Music]